Westworld season 2 episode 5 begins in
the week ahead timeline strands forces
are draining the flooded Valley and
fishing out the dead hosts bringing them
to the Mesa hub to try and fix them and
recover their code but Antoine finds
that a third of the hosts brains are
empty not like they're wiped but like
they never held data to begin with so
did someone put new empty brains in
these hosts what happened to their old
brains
maybe these empty hosts are decoys and
Dolores put their real brains in new
bodies so that they can escape West
world like how Maeve got a new body to
remove the explosive in her spine last
season Dolores said she used the valley
as a weapon so maybe these hosts in the
valley are part of her plan we also see
more of the cradle a kind of simulation
technology or time capsule someone has
destroyed the hosts backups it held
if the hosts no longer have backups
maybe it's now possible for them to
permanently die and like William the
robots are in real danger for the first
time strand makes a weird comment about
someone giving quite a story
he might mean Ford's story at least some
what's happening this season seems to be
part of Ford's last narrative he said
there'd be violence and surprises and a
birth of a new people both bernard and
william say that they're in ford's game
but strand looks at bernard and talks
about figuring out how the story turns
like in episode 1 it seems like strand
is trying to get information out of
bernard what does he think bernard knows
something about Peter Abernathy or James
Dallas or Ford and the general Skynet
shitstorm does strand know that Bernard
is a host bernie is acting weird there
are theories that this bernard is
actually a human host clone of arnold
although this whole week ahead timeline
is a simulation in the cradle to
interrogate bernard at this point we
still don't know but something is up
here in the previous week timeline Teddy
and Dolores arrived at Sweetwater Teddy
calls this place home because he and
Dolores lived here for 30 years but
Dolores says it's not really home they
see Clementine meeting the new host that
took over her role after Clem was
decommissioned
says the same scripted lines that Clem
said in her loop so this is proof of the
fakeness of life in Sweetwater and if
their lives were fake is Dolores and
Teddy's relationship real they go to a
field where they used to dream of
running away together someday but after
30 years in their loops someday never
came now that they're free teddie asks
Dolores to finally go start a life
together but Dolores feels she has to
stay and fight her war against humans in
a way her woke nurse makes her less free
she feels more responsibility now than
she did as an ignorant machine but
Dolores does decide that her love for
teddy is real and they have sex maybe
for the first time in their 30-year
relationship but it might also be their
last time Dolores has a weird metaphor
about burning weak cows to stop a
spreading sickness the point is she
thinks teddy is too nice to survive the
war ahead like in Episode three Teddy
let Craddock go free then Craddock went
on a killing spree in Las ruedas Teddy's
mercy is dangerous and with this
sickness metaphor it sounds like Dolores
is worried that Teddy's compassion might
spread so Dolores uses her human tech
Phil to overwrite Teddy's personality
the changes are so extreme that Phil
says Teddy might not survive these shots
from a pre-release of the episode show
Teddy's personality before and after
Dolores maxes out his aggression and
cruelty and sets his empathy to zero
those shots might not be canon but the
point is that Dolores destroys the man
Teddy was she sacrifices the one she
loves for the sake of her war like
Stannis with Shireen as Maeve argued
earlier it seems hypocritical for
Dolores to kill and control people when
she claims to be fighting for freedom
Dolores says that this is the only way
and that she knows how this story ends
so maybe she's got some master plan with
the valley and these hosts and the death
of Teddy but even if this wins her war
is it worth her becoming just like the
enemy she's fighting against Dolores
prepares the west wall
train to go to the Mesa hub and rescue
her host father Peter who was taken by
Charlotte in Episode three
after Dolores brutality towards teddy
you gotta wonder if Dolores is helping
Peter out of love or if he just needs
the data in his head for her plan Maeve
& Co get captured by Samurai hosts from
Shogun world Maeve uses her voice
commands on them but they don't work
because the Shogun hosts only know
Japanese that would explain why these
ghost nation hosts were immune earlier
they speak Lakota but Lisa is that all
hosts have many languages buried in
their code which shall probably come in
handy later Lee says Shogun world is
like West world but more violent and
Japanese so rich waves can wave katanas
around which doesn't seem very safe West
world's guns are one thing but it must
be hard to stop guests hurting
themselves with swords and things we
learned that Lee copied bits of Shogun
world off West world so there's a town
like Sweetwater with a place just like
the Mariposa saloon the hosts akane and
sakura are based on Maeve and Clementine
and the hosts Musashi and Hana yo rob a
carnies tea house just like Hector and
Armistice robbed Maeve's saloon lots of
these shots are direct recreations of
the west-world originals so this is a
classic West world brain [ __ ] using
repetition to make us question identity
what does it mean to be Maeve when
there's a Japanese copy of her it also
reflects the long history of Japanese
samurai films and westerns borrowing
from each other massages actor says it's
beautiful the way east and west used
each other's ideas and yet HBO keeps
restricting our videos for copyright so
go figure
the West world hosts have mixed
reactions to their Doppel BOTS Hector
doesn't trust Musashi armistice and
hanayo snake-charming and Maeve sees
herself in Akane Akane is motherly
relationship with Sakura is similar to
Mavis relationships with Clementine and
with her daughter
so when Akane kills to protect Sakura
from the Shogun's men Maeve decides to
help her that night the group is
attacked by the Shogun's ninjas who
abduct Sakura may have has visions and
his voices she seems to be tapping into
the mesh network that bernard mentioned
subconscious link between nearby hosts
so it's like Maeve is psychic and can
hack hosts with her mind she uses this
voice power to control and kill a ninja
when the Shogun's army arrives
Hector Musashi armistice and hanayo make
a distraction so Maeve Anna carne can
escape
turns out Maeve wasn't kidding about
leaving Hector for dead lis questions
whether Maeve should risk herself to
help Akane and Sakura arguing that
they're just machines but Maeve says
that her choices and love are more than
just code on the way to save Sakura we
see delle security have been slaughtered
by Shogun world hosts which is
impressive
like the battle of fort forlorn hope was
one thing those hosts had guns and nitro
but the Shogun hosts have swords and
somehow they beat delle security who
have assault rifles but they also have
walkie-talkie thingies Lee takes one
from a corpse maybe he's planning to
betray Maeve and rejoin the humans Maeve
and Coe pretend to be a Chinese envoy
and go meet the Shogun the Shogun's off
his loop but knockers his woke he's just
broken leaking brain fluid like bernard
was a carnie shows herself to the Shogun
who was shocked that she'd risk her life
for Sakura instead of running away it's
just like how Maeve risks her life to
rescue her daughter instead of leaving
West world last season the Shogun agrees
to release saccharum if Akane dances for
him that night maven Akane find the
Shogun has carved the shape of a cherry
blossom tree into Sakura's back the name
Sakura means cherry blossom in Japanese
Akane and may have talked about their
shared scripted story of a new world
which represents freedom to them Maeve
uses her voice power and offers to wake
Akane
show her the truth behind her simulated
world but Akane refuses and Maeve
respects her choice
so Akane can keep her grief for Sakura's
pain which kind of implies that love and
grief are illusions that Akane might
lose if she awoke but the way Maeve lets
Akane choose contrasts with Delores
forcing Teddy to her will though these
both might be paths to consciousness a
big theme of last season is that
suffering leads hosts to
Dolores makes Teddy suffer and says we
all need to suffer to grow and Maeve
lets Akane choose to feel Sakura's pain
these two different paths to
consciousness might reflect how Maeve
and Delores themselves first became
conscious Maeve chose to get off that
train but Delores is awakening with ford
was suspiciously similar to the coded
killing of Arnold he is Delores really
free and the stage is set for a car
neighs dance in the background these
banners show symbols of West world the
maze and the del estado project because
the best way to hide a conspiracy is to
show it's symbol everywhere the Shogun
kills Sakura to the horror of Akane and
Maeve of course they could probably
resurrect Sakura like Dolores raised
Craddock but maybe Sakura's death is
more meaningful if its final in episode
1 Arnold said that something's real when
it's irreplaceable Akane performs her
dance and ends it by ripping off the
Shogun's head kinda like in Zoolander
the title of this episode is Akane know
my which can mean a car neighs dance but
Akane also means deep red and this is a
bloody red dance just before the
Shogun's men kill may if she unlocks her
mutant power and reaches into the matrix
and makes all the Shogun's men kill each
other with her new power
mave can control all hosts she says she
found a new voice and now we use it and
then she picks up a sword but maybe mave
will use her power for something more
than killing before we saw Maeve use her
voice power to lead akane towards
consciousness Maeve's power can wake
hosts and the way bernard described the
mesh network a message could be sent to
nearby hosts who spread the message to
get more hosts if Maeve's voice works
through this network
maybe Maeve could chain wake hundreds of
hosts at once so West world continues to
ask complex questions about freedom and
control consciousness and identity who
what and when is bernard is Ford still
in control what's happening at the
valley is it okay for Dolores to control
hosts a Dolores and Teddy's lives real
what does it mean to be you if there
to use and what's the right way to use a
magic Wi-Fi superpower thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video
please like and subscribe and consider
supporting all shift acts on patreon you
can get behind the scenes stuff on the
discord topic votes
script streams and more thanks to
patrons Brett am benek Mike Feld Ellen
Scott Seligman Ashley Carter Carter and
Johnny axe Abel lion Kendra Henry and
Fisk Ranger Bonnie and honeycomb Cheers
you